it just it controlled my life
i was always worried about it i
was always thinking about it
it definitely
made me feel really like ashamed of how
i looked for sure i'm chris i'm 29 and i
started losing my hair at 20.
i was contested on sleeping in dance
starring in the show and it was just
such an exciting time
when my hair first started thinning the
hairline had moved way back in my head
it was kind of just rapidly
just kind of going instantly
[Music]
i couldn't
handle the thought of someone
looking at my hair or touching my hair
because of how bad it looked and i was
so ashamed of it
i was super young thinking i'm 21. i
should have
a
head full of hair you know i remember
being just so upset
there was never any really clear answers
of why
doctors were just kind of saying that it
was either hereditary or it can just
happen
most of the options had a lot of side
effects you know the medication made me
really worried that
if i was to take it is it worth the hair
growth
you know the hair transplant
isn't 100 guaranteed that it can stay
forever the best result we got was like
a hair growth cream
it took about three months for it to
kick in and
by like 22
it didn't come back so it was like a
good kind of six months of using this
cream and
it was just so exciting
so i was living in los angeles when i
received one of the
worst phone calls i
i probably could have ever got in my
life
my mum had passed away and i guess in
that time the stress was like
unbearable immediately my hair just
just started to fall out again i just
thought like that's that's it like it's
it's not gonna come back again
i was consistently trying to hide it
even for me to just go to the letterbox
i would put a hat on it was just
exhausting it was like
always worrying about
what i looked like that i just thought
the only option was to completely get
rid of it
being in the entertainment industry is
it's hard you're being judged every
second
on how you look
once i shave the hair off
the job i was given were just
all dad rolls or
literally like old man roles like in
inverted commas old man
it was just so
disappointing
that for me was like the final straw
when i started seeing those words
i was like i have to do something about
this
if i had known how simple getting a
hairpiece was
i would have done it years ago i
definitely think there is stigma around
hair pieces and toupees today
there's no difference with a woman
getting extensions and a guy getting
something for his hair i think it's
exactly the same thing
it doesn't matter to me at all that this
isn't my hair i actually
forget that it's not mine most of the
time um because it's just it's connected
to my head and
i feel amazing
i feel probably the best i've felt in
years i feel
so good about
the way i look i feel good on the inside
i felt like there wasn't enough talk
about hair loss the more we speak about
this
the more it becomes normal and the more
it's just a normal conversation
it takes a lot of courage and strength
to put your hand up and
ask for help
if you've had a similar experience to
this you can click the links below and
they'll give you the support that you
need